go on gumtree type in property for sale
and type in an area
private so you're dealing with the
seller direct
don't be a [ __ ] and just start calling
the sellers direct
make a post on facebook telling
investors that you've got some really
good deals coming up soon get your post
as an ad on facebook and start getting
loads of eyeballs
on your post
negotiate a really good price on a
property send an email to all your
investors with the detailed figures
make sure you have a clear call to
action at the end with a 3 000 pounds
finders fee when investors say they're
interested make them sign a
confidentiality agreement and then give
them all the details on the property and
give them a few days to make up their
mind when you have an investor that
wants it make them sign terms and
conditions and then once they've signed
on send them an invoice for three
thousand pounds
get paid three thousand six hundred
pounds and then tell the investor to
instruct their solicitor to contact the
seller anybody can be financially free